[Music]
very special Late Night with Conan
O'Brien tonight from the Larry Sanders
Show Janeane Garofalo and Buster
Poindexter
[Music]
they invited me aboard is because my ass
can be used as a flotation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my dreams in hotel
[Music]
now dance black [ __ ] boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a Conan O'Brien
[Music]
and now here's your host Oh No
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to our big circle line show
ladies and gentlemen we're in New York
Harbor in what show would be complete
without the man who saved my life in
Korea Andy Richter let's bring him out
here
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much and we
actually got people to come along on
this thing everyone in the studio
audience was being paid $800 that's
right
I'd also of course like to call
attention to the finest band in late
night TV the Max Weinberg 7 max I think
we should up I think we should call
attention very quickly to the beautiful
outfits being worn by Max and his band
tonight this Portland General Electric
out how much money yeah these are these
are the real thing we're experienced
cruisers and they okay that's right Andy
what do you think this whole ensemble
Max Weinberg and is periwinkle seven we
paid top dollar this whole thing ladies
and gentlemen is costing the network I
think in the neighborhood of 6.4 million
dollars yeah 6.4 million dollars this is
almost as much money as they spent on
the show and a hole that we did yeah we
did it I don't know if people saw that
anybody even though we get a show in a
hole in a hole it was the worst idea we
ever had it wasn't even a deep hole like
four feet yeah and we sort of just sort
of squatted in this hole yeah the entire
hour and Max and the guys didn't even
rent suits for that yeah this fish
should be better oh you know what we
forgot oh yeah let's get it right now
what do you think good look for the shot
away
of course of course when I put on a hat
like this it begs for an Alan Hale jewel
Ellen Hale jr. impersonation I think we
all want to see a now and II do his Alan
Hale jr. impression no no no that that's
pretty much all to block 40 minutes of
show time so yes it yeah we're gonna
have to get some guests terrific very
nice all right well listen we are out
here and I thought what better what
better way to start the show than with
some quick jokes about New York landmark
okay what do you think I think it we
have to all right now we're gonna see a
lot of incredible things here ladies and
gentlemen a lot of incredible sights on
this tour on this Circle Line tour I
shall point out it is the 50th
anniversary of the Circle Line and I
want to mention that right now I
actually get paid if I mentioned that
really yeah I can we can write off this
whole crappy trip all right now I want
to point out that we're gonna see some
incredible things Andy uh-huh yeah we're
gonna see the Empire State Building all
right
right yeah you know Andy I can't help it
it's hard to look at the Empire State
Building without thinking about that
famous monster King Kong know Leona
Helmsley Wow and the advantage of these
jokes ladies and gentleman is you can't
do these on Leno you can these are only
good at sea we have to do them that
we're also going to see of the Statue of
Liberty Andy which I don't know if
you're aware it was a gift from France
in 1886 oh yeah I did know that yeah you
know our gift of France of course was
Jerry Lewis I think I got the better end
of the deal yeah I think we did of
course of course there's the Javits
Center we're gonna see the Javits Center
sure which ladies and gentlemen is the
biggest Exhibition Centre in the Western
Hemisphere did you know that
no I didn't yeah the second biggest
place for exhibitions incidentally is x
square x squared
maritime law said to tell these jokes on
a boat ladies and gentlemen we don't
even weighted them and we didn't want to
do jokes on the open seats but
apparently it is a Coast Guard rule
maritime law for jokes
up top and they can't be that good
that's apparently part of the rule and
finally we're gonna see the Brooklyn
Bridge Brian D yeah which actually if
you didn't know this the Brooklyn Bridge
connects the borough of Manhattan to the
thousands of guys named Tony and I think
it's okay we just fulfilled our legal
obligations right all right we're fine
now actually this that we're legal now
we can now do the show all right well
ladies and gentlemen to make this whole
night special for everybody each member
of our audience has received a very
special and very nice commemorative
listen that's right they received a late
night circle line show commemorative
t-shirt look at these they're beautiful
that's beautiful
[Applause]
thank you that's great that's terrific
you know the line between enthusiasm and
mob like anger very thin yeah let's hope
we don't cross yeah let's let's hope we
just keep afloat all right now ladies
and gentlemen it is time to introduce
the crew of this marvelous vessel you
can't do a show like this without first
meeting the crew right isn't that fair
that's very fair all right so let's
start off with the man at the top ladies
I'm gonna say hello to captain ed Weber
Eddie there hi Colin
hi Andy let's go captain keep keep both
hands on the wheel please would you okay
all right now sir how are you how's it
going in the wheelhouse
anything to report nothing nothing yet I
haven't seen anything yet sir is it true
that you're good friends with captain
Hazelwood who told you that all right
that's fine we'll keep that to ourselves
if anybody here wants to get married he
can do it that's right if any members we
should point out now if any members of
the studio audience wish to get married
at any point just ask us captain Webber
we'll take care of it we also have an
addition to the real captain we have
Olli Olsen aboard who thinks he's the
captain
say hi to Olli for us
are you doing there oldie you okay yeah
man he's in a life struggle with that
wheel there
alright go easy on it oldie just for
anyone at home who's concerned he is
tied down yeah he's talking we can't
blow away yeah and he'll be selling fish
sticks after the show and do not
purchase them yeah all right I should
point out later on my our tour guide
today is Chris Calhoun we should get him
a hand
Chrissy you there where are we right now
oh we're just on the phone you left the
World Trade Center the Twin Towers there
yeah I could have told you that any
facts about the twin towers anything at
all pretty darn tall aren't they you're
a big help Chris I'm sorry I ever met
you all right let's move on we also have
leis and gentlemen no ship would be
complete without galley slaves
so let's everyone give a hand to the
galley slaves on board I thought we were
diesel-powered I anything Union thing oh
it's right can we just cut back quickly
Wiz doesn't it look like mick fleetwood
is at the end right there lady demonsaw
to Mick Fleetwood or Fleetwood Mac hey
it's work you know work that or is
really turning up the air off it's not
the most realism arrow we ever comments
all right anyway we're also very excited
ladies and gentlemen because we thought
it was important if we're gonna do a
show on the open sea that we should have
a rare form of aquatic sea life aboard
and actually earlier today a manatee was
caught in our rudder and got a little
bit mangled but he's fine now he's on
board and Andy and everybody please say
hello to our manatee
how are you there manatee just
hello everyone hi hello yeah hello just
just happy to be alive going in all
right happy to not be dead all right
thank you
thank you thank you for that ad-lib
manatee all right now ladies dumbest
people often put New York Harbor down a
lot they they say mean things about it
and we were legally required to do some
mean jokes about earlier we had to yeah
yeah we were forced to but it's wrong
it really is wrong to do that because
earlier today we found something very
wonderful and magical right here in New
York Harbor ladies and gentlemen we
found a genuine New York Harbor mermaid
hey Conan
what if they couldn't vote it I can make
your head spin Conan
that's okay I'm very tempted man but no
thank you
you don't know what you're missing I'm
the best I love you long time
alright thank you very much isn't that
nice isn't that nice we actually we have
children on board the ship now we're
gonna put them in a little skiff and
send them away
really Kate them alright and now lays
them in a very special special hello to
our special bartender tonight Isaac from
The Love Boat Ted Lange say hi to a
larvik
[Applause]
is a happy audience and I can tell
they've already been looking up a little
bit so we're going to take care of the
rest of the day for them all right I fix
special grog courtesy of the Lido deck
very nice all right that's all I think
special group the entire oh wow that's
nice and Isaac will have he and his
pirate cohorts will pass out grog to the
entire audience they'll be quite drunk
by the next commercial yeah that's good
and meanwhile ladies and gentlemen one
more time before we we're gonna go to
commercial now I understand you back
with Janeane Garofalo but when we come
back ladies and gentlemen will have
Janeane Garofalo here but before we do
let's hear it for the late-night Circle
Line dancers come on now ladies and
gentlemen you know let's let's be honest
we kid the circle line crew quite a bit
here and we do it because we think they
deserve it they're bad people but we
want to stress there really is a very
dedicated hard-working bunch that keeps
this old tub of float and will to give
you some idea Andy and I went out
yesterday and found out just who these
fine people are take a look Andy and I
are standing here on the Circle Line
pier they're getting the boat ready
behind us right now for our big show and
well we just thought it'd be fun to go
and take you through a tour of the
bowels of the ship hi Andy and I are
here right now with captain Edie Webber
he's the commander of the circle line 17
thanks for being with us
how'd he do so right boy do you ever get
these strong urge to run over pleasure
craft well that's I you see a couple of
Yahoo's from Jersey on their boat with
the radio blaring loud and they're
eating buffalo wings and guzzling Old
Milwaukee you just want to cut that
vessel in two don't you you know it
what are some of the great things we're
gonna see on the tour on the island well
undoubtedly the highlight of the tour
for most people that come on it is Lady
Liberty out at the Statue herself and
the world trade some of the tall
buildings that's what the tourists who
primarily ride the Circle Line come to
see you ever tear up a little bit when
you see our Lady Liberty
sometimes on our night cruises I do
because it's a kind of romantic looking
and she's an inspiring statue and
besides being the world's tallest
sculpture yes it does bring a tear to
your eye there's a rumor that you've
been sending these statue letters
unsolicited and maybe been asked to stop
who told you that captain Webber captain
Webber hates the French yeah tell us
about that
what nationality of tourists do you have
the most trouble with well I don't know
if I could say that on TV
sure you can I'd rather not we promise
this will never air the fridge there's
anything you can tell us about Chris the
tour guide he lies about the heights of
buildings and things like that the
Empire State Building 110 stories our
lady Lady Liberty with the bass 300 feet
above New York Harbor without the bass
151 feet
and what's this
[Music]
um you know I really feel like you've
gone too far this time
just too much look the head isn't big
enough for it it's what's the problem no
it's too much it's much too big it's too
you it's you know there's other people
involved in this thing it's not just you
I mean we could get you ahead if you
want to have you could do that
guys it's getting kind of late and quite
frankly I'm getting sick and tired of
these questions you're asking me so it's
okay with you I'd like to cut out now
well that's fine because actually we're
we're getting a little sick and tired of
you quite sick indeed
okay I think I did a lot of good Andy
how he did okay where's the dumper we're
gonna take a quick break then we're
gonna come back we'll see you in just a
second on a boat
I like your coming Janeane Garofalo
we'll be right out in just a second but
first let's check in with our tour guide
Chris and see where we are what are we
looking at over there Chris can you tell
us anything about it
Oh Conan England to your left that's the
77 story Chrysler Building it was once
the tallest building in the world really
the Chrysler Building that's really
incredible well I'd like to take a look
at the Chrysler Building a little closer
up I've got a little spyglass right here
just to see what it looks like there we
go I think that's it oh look at its Ed
Koch really
yeah and he's eating a being a giant tub
of peanut butter with an oversized spoon
well that's what Ed Koch does that's
kind of what he does best yeah yeah all
right always nice to see these it's only
right to start off would you care to
wear a silly show absolutely
oh great thank you very much is it this
good tassel in back yeah it's got I
think toss is it tackling back anyone
here no Castleman back you just know how
to chant boat boat boat right yeah thank
you thank you for that
you know we've learned we've learned
Janine that on the high seas anything
bounces a chance anything can be
converted how are you how's life going
I'm fine everything's fine is this mine
yes this is yours this is Isaac's punch
that good that is so amazing to to and
my thirtieth year
come to a point where I get a mixed
drink from Isaac the bartender isn't
that what it's all about okay yes I'll
be all the years bombing in comedy clubs
ten years it's all come to fruition
right there in this mug and it's all
worth yeah well if we could make it all
worthwhile then I think we haven't
really done our job yet okay why thank
you all right and you're free to eat the
orange at any point okay thanks
now life is going well for you tell us
what projects you involved in well I
just finished hosting a show for Comedy
Central called Comedy product uh-huh
which will be on either sometime in the
summer sometime in the fall I don't know
so this just is just turning out to be
for you the greatest year possible oh
yes you're a special went off without a
hitch well and you get a drink from
Isaac's yeah everything's just sort of
cascading now this is just goodness
cascading all over you right well the
Comedy Central thing was fine and then
the HBO one-night stand I did recently
was fine except for there was kind of a
weird stalker guy in the front row who I
mean who would think I would have a
stalker de Mille that's like really odd
but I would cuz I think I have like know
maybe 15 fans on the Internet across
this country maybe they're like they're
like a secret 1500 talker no well he was
sitting in the front row we taped at the
Fillmore in San Francisco and I had to
go there for sound check at 3:30 in
afternoon and he was there with a
t-shirt with my face on it so he had to
go and make one because they don't have
t-shirts with my face on that's a sign
of desperation right there that trouble
yeah and then he sat in the front row
for both shows and so I had him come up
on stage on the second show so they
could get coverage on him in case I die
or something so that people would be
aware of his physical appearance so that
in case I get murdered that this would
be the man to look to it would be the
guy it would be easy to find either with
your face on his chest yeah
I don't know I envy you I would kill for
a stalker I don't have a stalker Oh be
careful what you wish for
really I don't I look at the front row
here I see you know smiling faces
I get Regis stalker coming here you know
what I mean that's what I get wait
you're showing a shirt does it say Conan
on your shirt you're on tape now in case
something happens we know it was so
everyone's got a stalker except me oh
I'll get you one my wife's going down
the tubes fast he'll get one too I've
got this goofy hat all right now you're
understand you actually were working on
another project with Michael Moore yeah
I do I do some stuff occasionally for
Michael Moore who did Roger and me and
now he has a TV show called TV nation
and Michael Moore is like he's the
greatest guy but he's totally a guy who
likes to get to the bottom of things and
getting arrested is his favorite thing
and if he can get the correspondents
arrested he would like that too so I did
a piece as a correspondent on Greenwich
Beach and Greenwich Connecticut which is
off-limits to anyone outside of
Greenwich
so Michael wants to you know expose this
elitist exclusionary policy of Greenwich
because he feels no one can own the
water so he sent me out to go to get a
beach pass in Greenwich Connecticut and
of course I don't live there so they
wouldn't give me one but he wants like a
hoo-ha but you know with me I go up
there and say can I get it get a pass
and the woman says do you live here and
I said no she goes so I'm sorry you
can't have one I'm like okay thanks bye
so that's like thank you very much for
your time so that wasn't good enough I
don't want to be of any more bother I'll
be leaving now and taking my TV crew
with okay that's fine and then I take
the worst 60 minutes it gets worse than
that then so he puts me in a boat to try
and row on to to Venice Beach which
doesn't work on that Venice Beach
Greenwich Beach doesn't work I'm like
okay fine I can't go on okay bye row
away then drive on they wouldn't let me
on so then finally it wasn't working so
I just dove in the water
I just tried to swim on in my clothes
and I had glasses on I swim in and it
took me like 30 minutes to swim to where
it's illegal and they have the
coastguard waiting for me or the
Greenwich coastguard and then there's
cops waiting for me on the beach but I
have to swim in there's nowhere for me
to go and the
people of Greenwich were waiting for me
on the beach to Hertling insulted
screaming and yelling and I was so
willing to give them the better than the
doubt yet they really turned out to be a
very unpleasant group of people very
angry with you very angry with me they
beat you with a they were yelling and
hurling insults and I'm such a loser
like I revert if there were some young
people yelling at me and I went has
anybody ever seen reality bites and so
that quilled a couple of them first
second but then there was like otherwise
older ones and I said bye-bye love did
you enjoy that Paul Rhys everybody likes
Paul Reiser right and that didn't work
and they were yelling at me and no and
we were all wet I don't know totally wet
and they had to have a lawyer for TV
nation come down and beg the cops to let
me run to a waiting car over the thing
so that was bad no Janine you're with us
now and you're on a boat I'm in saying
you're drinking one of Isaac's drink and
everything's fine now all right we're
gonna take a quick break we'll have a
little more with Janeane Garofalo when
we come back so we'll see you in just a
second stick around
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a ladies and gentlemen as you
all know we are sailing here in New York
Harbor and we're very excited despite a
little bit of drizzle and the fact that
Janine you're now very sick aren't you
she's feeling really seasick and well
the whole thing's falling apart around
us but we're very excited very very
excited ladies and gentlemen because
right now we have a very special treat
in store for you I'm sure everyone out
there in TV land and here on the boat is
aware a famous illusionist David
Copperfield probably the most famous
illusionist of all time right and ladies
and gentlemen he's not just a magician
he's an illusionist which is a whole
other grade higher than magician you
know not just some crappy magician he's
an illusionist news Eunice thank you
anyway you all know how David
Copperfield is most famous for once
making the Statue of Liberty disappear
that's right well ladies and gentlemen
were privileged to have him aboard today
to repeat this amazing trick for the
first time ever on a boat I'm gonna
start crying
[Laughter]
please welcome David Copperfield
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen how does he do it
and more importantly why does he do it I
don't know it's incredible how do we let
him why do we let him do it how is it
we're all going to take a break here
we're going to recover from what I think
may be the most incredible thing
anyone's ever seen anywhere and we'll be
right back so stick around you'll see in
a second
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
ok everybody we're back you know and
Yvgeny and I've been thinking since
we're out here in the middle of New York
Harbor and since we actually find
ourselves in the bow of the boat and
since we happen to have a working 19th
century Canon it seems like we ought to
take this opportunity to declare war on
New Jersey it's not a good idea make
sense yeah all right now Andy what
target have we loaded up we're at the
Colgate sign in Jersey City okay big
sign and clock because nothing would
strike about parts of New Jerseyans more
than to destroy their coal cage side to
destroy the Colgate sign would make New
Jersey people angry enough that they
would actually go to war with New York
all right
I'm but I'll buy it okay should we do it
yep I'm ready fire when ready Andy you
want to do it or should I I'll do it
go ahead there we go you can cover your
ears go baby go burn mama burn oh man
this is taking longer than we expected
go yeah
my my the New Jersey coastline is
beautiful I should come down here more
often what the hell was that don't they
know amid conch
my god that man gets around free Cape
Cod oh that was fun all right ladies and
gentlemen I think
Wow I think we might be in trouble that
sounds like a siren yeah let's not
mention the cannon let's check this out
come on Janine it's part of the big hear
you talking
hold this to need a ladies and gentlemen
it's the New York City Fire Department
they might be a little angry yes we
understand that's a great show that's a
terrific program thank you Monday
[Applause]
very nice very nice water spraying thank
you nice job
that's terrific ladies and gentlemen it
sounds like money is gonna be a great
show we'll take a break we'll be right
back we'll see in a moment love the Hat
please sit down enjoy thank you for
being with understand you're in a very
good mood I am in such a pen I think
what is the greatest summer of my life
Oh tell us about it what's going on it's
peace in the Middle East this whole
peace in the Middle East thing has
really got my skirt blowing up you know
I remember when they first started I
remember starting diplomats have used
that expression when talking about peace
in the Middle East should go ahead
shamone perez Yasser Arafat this has
been two years ago they started
hammering this thing out in a cute
little maestra net in downtown Oslo the
old hammers old nation we met of course
and they came to the door
old lady how much soul answers the door
all right boys I wish you a lot of luck
with your peace accord but I got a new
white shag carpet here so take your
shoes off so it's not much the rug you
know of course
so Shimon took off his shoes yes it took
off his sandals I think they were
Birkenstocks and they started hammering
hammering out this piece of cord
hammering and after about three hours
shamone was getting a little thirsty and
he said you know
yes I'm thirsty I'm gonna go to the
kitchen and get some orange juice
would you like orange juice it would be
good so he tiptoed over to the kitchen
in his stocking feet and while he was
gone Arafat hocked a loogie right nice
shoe he comes back they drink the orange
juice they hammer they hammer this
Middle East peace accord
after about two hours Simone's thirsty
against his orange juice like the
hollering shoes he tiptoes back to the
kitchen
Arafat Oh hocks a loogie in his other
shoe this happens about four or five
times finally it's the end of the day
these guys are tired of hammering so
they call it a day shamone puts his
shoes
and it's like and he says when when when
will it end - spitting at this Jews the
pig in the orange juice in a story which
I think brought us all together all
across the globe buster thank you very
much for not only singing but doing a
story about spit and urine we thank you
my god bless you
and Jenna take a quick break we'll be
right back let's eat is like a Busta
point gentleman that is our show for the
night we're sailing the Portugal will
see a Monday bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]